let's bring you some breaking news now
coming in from afghanistan we're
receiving reports of an explosion inside
a shia mosque in the southern city of
kandahar security sources say there are
casualties stephanie decker is in kabul
let's bring her in to the show so what
can you tell us about this explosion
well we're just hearing news of this in
the last 15 minutes or so so we're
trying to verify exact details i'm just
getting some video sent to me now
it does look like again very similar
scenes to what we saw in kunduz
last friday
sammy ambulances
casualty count at the moment unconfirmed
but it does seem that there are
casualties kandahar is in the south of
the country this is really taliban
heartland the seat of power of the
taliban from what we understand this
explosion happened in or near a shia
mosque we're trying to verify exact
details at the moment it's just breaking
news as you mentioned but certainly it's
a concern we have a pattern it seems
yester last friday again as a hazara
minority shia mosque in kunduz targeted
with
isis k
suicide bomber who managed to enter the
mosque detonate himself and kill over 60
people and now it seems we've had
another explosion during friday prayers
on a friday in a mosque shia mosque this
time in the south in kandahar but we
will of course bring you more details
once we get them confirmed as to what
exactly happened and how many casualties
there are believed um to have been
all right and obviously not a good start
to friday there we're also hearing
reports of a taliban operation underway
against isil what can you tell us about
that
yes the taliban confirming that they
have managed to destroy a key taliba a
key isis k isis in afghanistan hideout
in mazzari sharif this is in the north
of the country so it's obvious that
there is
a concerted effort campaign underway by
the taliban to target isil k
areas i think it was interesting two
days ago we had a press conference by
the spokesperson from the interior
ministry and beforehand sami we've been
interviewing members of the taliban
interview interview the head of kabul
security just a couple of days ago and
they've always maintained that it the
isis k threat is under control that they
have it sorted it was interesting two
days ago the interior ministry
spokesperson giving a message to taliban
fighters to look inward saying if you
feel that anyone
could be an isil k operative within your
ranks he needs
to be
reported and then saying that they will
be held to account under sharia law they
will be held to count under treason and
that the entire unit including the
commander will be dissolved so there is
an admittance now that the infiltration
uh by isis k of taliban ranks could be a
problem but certainly yes we've seen a
concerted campaign over the last couple
of weeks of taliban trying to you know
clamp down on the issue but the problem
is sami unlike syria and iraq what we
saw in the past in terms of geography
isis k here operates more in terms of
his sleeper cell mode so far harder i
think um to deal with but certainly a
message from them taliban always playing
the security card thing that they can
maintain the only ones that can maintain
security here and this is challenging
that
all right let's leave it there thanks so
much stephanie decker